four people are still unaccounted for in
the devastating car fire near red in
California new cell phone video shows
homeowners fleeing the intense flames it
is now the seventh most destructive
wildfire in California history the
Mendocino complex fires destroyed more
buildings yesterday
high winds forced firefighters to
scramble to contain the flames this
morning there are 17 large wildfires
burning statewide media viene al is in
Lakeport California midday a good
morning well good morning you know
behind me there used to be about bar and
now all that's left is a bunch of scrap
metal and hotspots right now we
understand at this area these are the
structures that were lost overnight and
they're the first to go up since Sunday
now firefighters tell us they are making
progress on this blaze but right now
there are still more than 12,000
structures being threatened firefighters
faced a wall of flames as high as 40
feet tall as winds push this new armed
are the medicine no complex fire towards
homes we had really erratic fire
behavior we had spot fires we had fire
pushing over and over ridges down into
canyons firefighters work quickly to put
out spot fires but they were unable to
stop the flames from reaching buildings
nearby one homeowner stood shoulder to
shoulder with firefighters as the
Wildfire approached it's my house what
else am I gonna do so I try to do
everything I can to save it while his
home was saved other nearby structures
were destroyed we can see from the road
that there were whether it was barns
whether his homes that there were
structures involved in fire farther
north hundreds lost everything
after the car fire suddenly exploded
last week newly released cell phone
video shows the fires initial fury forty
people working at this hospital lost
their homes including dr. Edwards of
Wanda here we were on this cul-de-sac
this neighborhood and then we go away
and two hours later it's gone as
homeowners try to come to grips with
their losses
firefighters are bracing for what's
turning out to be a relentless fire
season I don't care where you stand on
your opinion of global warming there's
something changing and we're seeing
fires that have never happened in this
area before
last month took a major toll on
California's firefighting budget in the
month of July they spent a hundred and
fifteen million dollars fighting these
wildfires that is a quarter of their
budget for this year Anthony a huge cost
Maria thanks so much